and every single day uh right here on
the rich eisen show we are thrilled uh
on nbc sports on peacock
to hand over the reigns every single day
to my next guest and michael smith who
i've not spoken to in quite some time so
you will have to say
and send my best to him from brother
from another a peacock original michael
holly on the show how are you michael
doing well rich i love patriots fans man
don't don't move on
never move on from oh seven i knew
somebody was gonna say that i just
didn't expect anybody from
western new york to bring it up and then
how many patriots fans you have on the
show
well mike uh michael uh we've got chris
brockman across the way he stands alone
but he is the uh he is the
personification of masshole
um and so he
he and he you proudly uh let that freak
flag fly every single day i'm from maine
though michael so it's it's fine
it's not it's still new england no i
understand the area i'm not michael we
talked about before
um that that that patriots fans are the
only
humans on the planet who refer to the
tuck rule game as the snow game
they're the only ones exactly you know
you got to switch it around
you got you got to switch it around to
suit your purposes now
uh apparently after that game according
to uh
roland williams who was a who was a
tight end for the raiders at the time i
love him
according to him he said after the game
tom brady
walked around you know shaking hands
dapping each other up he went to every
raider and said good game
it was a fumble good game it was a
fumble and it was a fumble but
hey he's such a good guy it was a rule
at the time you just take advantage of
the rules tb12
an honest good man and i'm you know not
just saying that because my children
adore him but he's a university of
michigan uh stellar
hall of famer so uh that's part of the
reason why i bring that up um
so they still play football in michigan
by the way richard
that's nbc sports on peacock on nbc
sports on peacock violence that just
happened right there
i need to i need to i need i need to
call somebody yeah they do they do play
i grew up in ohio i mean i i'm a buckeye
what
am i supposed to say you know i was just
no i was
told to hate michigan football all
things michigan now so you're
you're you're a good uh individual to
ask since not only you
just refer to yourself as a buckeye
cause from you're from ohio but you're
an author
and you're also a co-host of a show uh
that's on this
on this uh channel so uh why is it the
ohio state michael
is it to prevent me from confusing it
from an ohio state university is that
what it is arrogance
it is just arrogance okay at least you
own that the
the ohio state university stop nobody's
confused
go with ohio state i don't care i call
it the ohio state just to be messing
around but come on
so oh so what are you uh
what are you and michael have uh on tap
today what are you going to talk about
coming up you know honestly and one of
the great things about our show rich is
that we just
uh we don't pretend that there's not a
world right
going on outside of sports and so uh
michael wasn't on yesterday i think he
was running away and
he was afraid of what was going to
happen uh to our society
so he ran away he wasn't on yesterday
today he's going to come on i think he i
just talked to him about 15 minutes ago
he said his nerves are still bad
uh he's going to talk about election
stuff and just how it how it
uh how it hits him and how how it hit
his family and
how it's hitting his family i'm going to
talk with eddie gload
he's really a smart guy he's been on
msnbc he's got a book out about
uh james baldwin and then we're also
going to talk with our brother from
another
another brother chris sims don't worry
about how we're brothers
you know we might have you know
different daddies different mamas
whatever but
don't worry about that don't worry about
the dna
we're we're family yeah we're gonna have
him on too that reminds me of that
moment to the combine a couple of years
ago when dion's on the field
watching the defensive backs and i
forget which defensive back that was on
the field
but he was a a brother of a player a
receiver in the nfl
and i just asked out loud has a brother
ever covered a brother
in the nfl and dion says you mean a
black man and i'm like oh come on
dion that's that is not that is not what
we're going for here in this combine
coverage but that's prime
that's one of my favorite people you
can't set them up like that you know
what you're going to get
i didn't actually you know what normally
i could see that one coming i totally
i was being honest like has has there
ever been a set of brothers
who are on the other side of the line of
scrimmage covering each other
you know um and that was dion's response
so that's that's what's coming up on
your show michael smith has resurfaced
he's good we're
he's ready to roll back okay he is back
he's ready to go
um so i'm i'm curious i'm curious
to what he's going to say you know what
else i've known michael smith for over
20 years but i think what we're finding
out
during this show i was counting for a
while i think we're on show
together number 38 39 somewhere in there
yep what i'm finding out
is that i'm i'm the freaking optimist
how is that possible i'm the optimist
among us like he i'm the one who
has to talk him down and and tell him
it's going to be all right i just never
thought
that was that would be our relationship
i always i went into this thinking that
he was a
a nicer person i am he's not um
well i went in thinking that he was a
little bit more optimistic
than i am he's not so we're learning
about each other even though we've known
each other for
a couple of decades well you know what
that's what happens uh when you do a
show with somebody else you get to know
them uh although i turn to
my uh social media grand maester here on
the show as he likes to be known
uh who knows you a lot better than i
would to see if that's accurate uh tj
jefferson
um do you want to tell michael is that
appropriate of michael holly is
not usually an optimist is that where
you be your assessment of him i mean
it's hard to say rich because you know
when we were you know
18 20 year old men we were pretty
optimistic about everything nice
i like that then you get older and life
tends to beat you down so
you know you're not so optimistic is
there anything that i should know about
tj
michael that i might not know about is
there anything i should know about tj
you know i'll tell you this about tj you
know tj
uh really could be uh
running the media world right now he
could be running the sports media world
i always
always said that now he's he's well he's
not modest
you know that
uh he may be too modest to tell you this
we had some
some young aspiring sports journalists
uh way back at point park
university as my fact was point park
college when we went there
way back at point park college and and a
couple of people are working in the
media right now
but he was the smartest one tj was the
smartest one but he was also
he uh he had a sense of humor uh
and we didn't so he he could make people
laugh and because he made people laugh
so much he didn't always
he didn't always do what he had the
ability to do
so he wouldn't always go to class is
that right
tj you skipping out i mean here's the
deal
i remember being playing
he he took me in he took me in when i
was about
uh homeless i was almost homeless in
college
because uh and it's a long story it's a
long time ago
it was a long time ago i'm a married man
now i'm happy got three kids this is a
long time ago
a long time ago he may have been
involved in ex that he was living with
at the time
so he needed a place to live with my
girlfriend i live my girl with my
girlfriend
and just imagine this she just didn't
want me to live there anymore so
it makes sense um i i had no place to go
and tj
and uh two other guys took me in mount
washington
pennsylvania a mount washington
apartment and so
they allowed me to sleep on the couch so
some of the best times i've ever had
i was living with those guys well it's
funny again when we we heard that um
you know nbc sports on peacock was going
to build out the channel
and that brother from from another was
uh going to be on after us and that you
were on it
he he says uh tj says what he says
literally
once a day oh i know that guy like and
we're like you know that guy
i mean he literally knows everybody he
is he is uh the forest gump of our
program and i say that with the utmost
of love and respect
he's a lovable guy he's met everybody
he's surprised he's successful
and you know um and he's also smarter
than he really thinks he is
and um because you say he's the smartest
guy michael then why does he like the
cowboys and the clippers
and the mets how does that happen and
the sixers
well he likes the cowboys i'm sure he
told you the story about how he used to
be
i have not to him yet so arrogant you're
so arrogant with the cowboys he uh
not anymore started off and i left oh
yeah that's right he can't
well no it's not just he's humiliated me
oh man he used to humiliate me though
look i there was a point in the early
90s when we were winning super bowls and
we were good
i was the definition oh yes
i was the definition of obnoxious cowboy
fan that guy stephen a smith was talking
yes
that was oh by the way one thousand
percent me
in the early to mid 90s in um super bowl
what was it the super bowl 27 right
i went to akron i watched the buffalo
dallas game with michael
he put money on the bills that game and
we know how that went dallas scored 52
points
i i celebrated with every single point
uh he had a record player with slick
rick the song was called i shouldn't
have done it
i played that song after every touchdown
over and over the entire game
imagine i should have put you out but
the only reason i didn't put you out is
because you had taken care of me in
college so i felt
uh just i got a fit of conscience but i
really did it was so annoying rich it
was the worst super bowl still to this
day worst super bowl experience
well i was pretty bad well michael i got
to tell you it's great uh
sharing a house with you right here on
peacock um
i'm sure your producers are probably
like why isn't michael in the chair you
really have to be on there in about five
minutes so
i'm gonna send you off uh to you uh to
your show and we'll we'll send it to you
in about five minutes time thanks for
coming on let's make a regular thing out
of this
i i'd love to uh in all seriousness big
fan have been
for a long time and uh people in in
boston
as you know uh people in boston have
been talking about you
what one one fan in particular uh i
won't say any names but has always been
talking about
rich eyes and rich i had no rich eyes
you're talking about my brother-in-law
michael i'm sure you're talking about
scott schuster my brother-in-law who
loves you by the way he speaks about you
very well
michael great guy he's a great guy and
he is and he loves he loves his
brother-in-law so you're doing something
right
i appreciate you happy to be on here and
i'm happy to be in conversation with you
every week
i feel i feel the same way about him
although he and brockman can go neck and
neck in uh in terms of mass homelessness
oh yeah they can go neck and neck
compare me to scott
well they're both syracuse guys too but
uh i know i say that with the ultimate
respect
to my lovely brother-in-law um might be
out there listening and watching uh
michael
we'll we'll see you soon all right
brother all right rich
all right tj you got it that's uh that's
michael holly hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here